well this isn't going to get disliked at
all so the e referendum on June 23rd is
one of the most politically important
decisions of our lifetime and as the
young Korea scientist just coming to the
end of his ph.d my main concerns with
the referendum are UK universities
research and science of course there are
other areas of concern but I'm not an
economist or a politician I'm a
scientist and a student so I'm only
going to talk about those areas that I
feel I'm qualified to talk about and
there will be a series of references
down there in the description where I'm
pulling all of this information from as
well as being some further reading so
how would a brexit impact the UK's
universities and its research activities
well to answer that question we have to
look at how you can universities and UK
researchers are integrated into Europe
research is a significant part of the EU
budget 10 billion euros last year and EU
funding forms a significant part of UK
science funding for two reasons firstly
UK scientists are very good at winning
EU funding we actually pay in about 12
pounds per person per year into the EU
Research Fund and we receive back about
15 pounds per person per year which
means they're actually net plus about
200 million pounds per year just by
being part of the EU the UK contributes
just over 11 percent of the EU s budget
but in the last seven years
funding cycle known as fp7 we secured
15.5% of the suns awarded meaning about
7 billion euros and secondly the UK
invest are less in science than other
comparable nations and this means the EU
funding forms a much larger percentage
of the total research funds available in
this country than elsewhere so the EU
forms an incredibly important part of
science and research funding here in the
UK but perhaps even more importantly of
our researchers more than 15% of
teaching and research staff employed by
UK universities were non British EU
nationals and those researchers are some
of the most respected in their fields
more than half of mid-career grants
given out by the ERC in UK universities
are held by researchers from other EU
countries here in part thanks to freedom
of movement and UK based research has so
far secured more than 1/5 of all funds
dispersed by the ERC with four of the
top ten institutions being British
Oxford Cambridge Imperial and UCL and
between them hosting some 380 ERC backed
projects this close link between British
science in the EU allows for lots of
collaboration which in the scientific
world is king in 1981 84% of British
research was published barring just a
British address by last year that figure
was 48 percent in America is still 67
percent this high rate of international
collaboration in British science allows
our tiny country with just naught point
nine percent of the world's population
3.2 percent of its R&D expenditure and
4.1 percent of all of its researchers to
account for fifteen point nine percent
of the world's most highly cited
scientific research articles that
possess number one globally for
high-quality science and that position
would without doubt be jeopardized by
leaving the EU so Steve Smith the
vice-chancellor of XD University and an
international relations specialist said
quote leaving would be a disaster of
course it would damage UK research and
universities in terms of attracting the
best staff students and funding but to
be honest that's not the biggest issue
all the evidence in the world shows that
the best research is done by people
working internationally the most
successful knowledge economy is where
people publish together with people in
other countries a membership makes that
immeasurably easier ultimately it's
about the quality of the work even if
you could make up the funding shortfall
from leaving the EU you'd be running
counter to the way that the world
knowledge economy is moving quite apart
from being a researcher as a student a
sudden dearth of funds caused by brexit
and yes there are arguments that Britain
could follow Switzerland Norway in
taking Pyne EU projects but not being a
member of the EU but that would be more
expensive and treacherous see what
happened to Switzerland in 2014 after
its citizens voted to restrict
immigration would substantially change
my student experience for me in
particular without funding I wouldn't
have a PhD or a world-leading supervisor
even if I wasn't directly dependent on
EU funding for my PhD or undergraduate
the lack of funds that would result from
a brexit would result in lower quality
teaching less money for student
resources and an
ability to take part in EU wide projects
such as the Erasmus scheme which has
benefited over 200,000 UK students and
20,000 staff and it would also lead to a
less diverse student population reducing
the opportunities I'd have to be exposed
to people from other cultures and make
friends with people who live in nice
places that I can visit in the summer as
a scientist I see no option but to vote
remain on June 23rd and I'm no alone in
a recent survey conducted by the journal
Nature over 80 percent of scientists
polled agreed that we should remain in
the EU and furthermore that both British
and European science would substantially
lose out from a brexit scientific
progress would almost certainly be
severely setback by voting to leave the
European Union and as a scientist that
makes the decision for me I'll be voting
to remain on June 23rd and when you
consider how you're going to be voting
I'd like to implore you to consider the
UK's global lead in science and how
voting to leave would jeopardize it
thank you for watching the argument is
that it's not a fair system and I'm
going to try and argue that the system
is not perfect but the problems that we
see are not coming from Oxbridge this is
because while the atmosphere is
transparent to radiation with visible
wavelengths light it's not transparent
of radiation with thermal wavelengths or
heat radiation so thermal radiation
given off by the Earth's surface then
gets absorbed by the atmosphere just
above the surface which